first example they give us this equation
of our function and what we're trying to
figure out is does the graph go up to
the right down to the right up to the
left or down to the left well the first
thing what we're gonna do is we're gonna
zero in on this highest degree term of
the polynomial that's the one with the
highest power the highest exponent here
and then what we're gonna do is we're
gonna look at the leading coefficient so
you can see the leading coefficient is
negative and what that tells us is about
the right end behavior so that means if
it's negative as X gets larger and
larger x is going to go down towards
negative infinity okay now because this
is an even degree when we go to the left
it's also going to have the same end
behavior as the right so it's going to
go down towards negative infinity so
when it's even 3 they're gonna both go
down or both go up but the leading
coefficient if it's negative that tells
you about the right end behavior
negative means it's going down to
negative infinity if this is positive
would tell you it's going up to positive
infinity now if it's an odd degree the
left brand behavior they're gonna be
opposite they're gonna go in opposite
directions now if you forget all of that
which sometimes it's easy to do is just
do it little tests just say let's say X
is 10 for example 10 to the fourth power
is 10,000 times negative 3 is negative
30,000 so when I go over here to X is 10
I'm way down here at negative 30,000
this term is growing much faster than
these two terms so I can effectively
ignore these and just focus on this term
because it's growing the fastest so
that's how I know it's going down to the
right now if I put in a negative 10 a
negative to an even power is gonna be
positive so negative 10 to the 4th is
still positive 10,000 times negative 3
is negative 30,000 so I know that's
going down to the left but what we want
to talk about now is how do we write
this in the limit notation so the limit
as X approaches negative infinity f of X
approaches blank now what this means is
as X is going to negative infinity as
I'm going to the left what happens to f
of X f of X are the Y values and you can
see the Y values are going down to
negative infinity if we do the limit as
X approaches positive infinity meaning
is we go to the right f of X is going to
approach negative infinity as well
because it's going down so this is the
notation now if you notice you
l am which is just an abbreviation for
limit and we have as a subscript a
little bit below the line like submarine
right below the water X approaches
negative infinity and then at the same
level as the limit here we've got the f
of X which represents the Y values and
we have this arrow telling us whether
it's approaching a positive infinity or
negative infinity okay let's do the next
example I think you've got the idea here
so in this one we can see that the
leading coefficients positive so as we
go to the right this is going to go up
to positive infinity we have an odd
degree so as we go to the left it's
going to go the opposite direction like
so but to write the notation and limit
notation we have the limit as X
approaches negative infinity that means
as we're going to the left the Y values
f of X approach negative infinity
they're going down to negative infinity
and then the limit as X approaches
positive infinity meaning as we're going
to the right on the x axis the Y values
f of X right approach it's going up
towards positive infinity so that's the
idea here how to describe the end
behavior using limit notation I hope
that helped you understand it a lot
better subscribe to the channel
check out some of my other videos on
Mario's math tutor YouTube channel and I
look forward to helping you in the
future videos I'll talk to you soon